♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YOU REMEMBER
MICHAEL COHEN, A LAWYER IN
NEW YORK, THE PRESIDENT’S
LAWYER.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO, HE WAS
INDICTED FOR TAX EVASION AMONG
OTHER THINGS AND WENT TO PRISON.
AND THE TOPIC OF MICHAEL COHEN
COMES UP, THE ONE THING EVERYONE
WHO KNOWS MICHAEL: MICHAEL COHEN
AGREE ON, THE ONE THING, IS HE
IS A SLEAZE BALL.
NOT A MINOR SLEAZE BALL, BUT AN
EPIC SLEAZE BALL, HOLLYWOOD
LEVEL FLEAS FALL.
IF THEY EVER MAKE "SLEAZE BALL:
THE MOVIE," MICHAEL COHEN WILL
PLAY THE LEAD AND BE IN EVERY
SEQUEL, TOO, HE WAS BORN FOR
THAT ROLE.
WHAT’S INTERESTING TO NOTE AMONG
MICHAEL COHEN’S CLOSE PERSONAL
FRIENDS IS AN ANCHOR ON THE
CABLE NEWS NETWORK, NOT JUST ANY
CNN ANCHOR COME UP WITH THE CNN
ANCHOR GIVEN THE MOST OVERHEATED
POSSIBLE MORAL LECTURES, AND THE
GOD HIMSELF, THE BLESSED MOTHER
IF NECESSARY, IF HE SCHOOLED YOU
FOR NOT LIVING UP TO HIS HIGH
ETHICAL STANDARDS.
THAT MAN’S NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
CHARLES CUOMO, SON OF ONE
GOVERNOR, BROTHER OF ANOTHER, A
YALE GRADUATE, WEIGHT LIFTER,
DEEPLY GOOD PERSON.
ALSO, WE NOW LEARN, A BUDDY OF
MICHAEL COHEN ONES.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
AUDIO TAPE OF A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE TECHNICAL MEN,
APPARENTLY MANY TAPES LIKE THIS,
BUT TONIGHT WE WILL PLAY
JUST A PORTION OF ONE.
BEFORE YOU LISTEN TO THIS, TRY
TO REMEMBER WHAT CHRIS CUOMO
SOUNDS LIKE WHEN YOU LISTEN TO
HIM ON TELEVISION, YOU’VE SEEN
HIM, ADMIT IT.
AND THEN THAT MEMORY, THE MORAL
CHRIS CUOMO, TO THE GUY YOU HERE
IN THIS RECORDING.
HERE YOU GO.
>> YOU KNOW, I’M ALWAYS CAREFUL
WHEN I TALK TO MEDIA.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW HOW MANY [BLEEP]
PHONE CALLS I’VE GOTTEN FROM
PEOPLE AT ABC WHO SAY REPORTERS
ARE CALLING AND LYING ABOUT
THINGS THEY HEARD ABOUT ME TO
TRY TO GET STORIES ABOUT ME WHEN
I WAS AT ABC?
GUYS CALLING AND SAYING "I HEAR
HE WAS THE CHARLIE ROSE OF EBC,
USED TO INVITE WOMEN TO THE
HOTEL."
DRY LOOKED LIKE THE [BLEEP] KIND
OF GUY WHO HAS TO DO THAT?
I HAVE A GOOD SOURCE THAT SAID
HE FORCED ONE WOMAN TO HAVE SEX,
I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF YOU HEARD
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THERE IS NO WOMAN.
WOMEN WHO DO WORK THEY’RE
SAYING, YEAH, YOU KNOW, AND HE
WAS NAMING ME WITH OTHER GUYS,
WE’VE ALL DONE THIS TO EACH
OTHER ONCE IN THE ELEVATOR AND
HE PUT HIS HAND ON MY SHOULDER
AND MADE ME VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
I MEAN, WHAT THE [BLEEP]?
IS A PROBLEM, AND I’VE ALWAYS
TOLD YOU, THE MEDIA IS NOT YOUR
FRIEND.
>> NO.
>> Tucker: WALL.
IF THERE A LOT TO UNPACK HERE,
BUT CHRIS CUOMO IS AGITATED,
MAD, REALLY MAD, AND WHAT MAKES
HIM MADDEST OF ALL?
THE SUGGESTION HE HAS TO ACT
LIKE SOME OLD GUY, CHARLIE ROSE,
TO GET THE LADIES, SANDBAGGING
WOMEN’S AND HOTEL ROOM WITH AN
OPEN BATHROBE.
"DO I LOOK LIKE THE KIND OF LIKE
US TO DO THAT?"
THE RESPONSE, "SURE, WHY NOT."
BUT CHRIS CUOMO DISAGREES.
HE DOESN’T NEED CHEESY TRICKS
LIKE THAT.
CHRIS CUOMO IS ON TELEVISION.
CHRIS CUOMO COULD BENCH PRESS
YOUR SUBARU COME OPEN BACK
BATHROBES ARE FOR LOSERS.
YOU KNOW WHO IS A LOSER?
ALL THOSE WOMEN WHO KEEP
ACCUSING CHRIS CUOMO OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THEY CLAIM HE BOTHERED THEM IN
ELEVATORS.
NOW, IF WOMEN MADE THOSE CLAIMS
AGAINST YOU, CHRIS CUOMO MIGHT
VERY WELL DENOUNCE YOU ON HIS TV
SHOW, BECAUSE WE ARE FIRING AND
BANISHMENT FROM DECENT SOCIETY.
THESE ARE WOMEN MAKING THE
CHARGES, AFTER ALL.
YOU MUST BELIEVE WOMEN.
WOMEN’S VOICES MUST BE HEARD.
ME TOO AND ALL OF THAT.
THAT IS NOT WHAT CHRIS CUOMO
TELLS HIS FRIEND, MICHAEL COMEY.
YOU GET THE SENSE NEITHER ONE OF
THESE GUYS IS
A BIG FEMINIST.
THEY CAN LET THEIR HAIR DOWN AND
BE THEMSELVES, SO HE SPARES HIM
THE ME TO LECTURE.
NOTHING FLATTERING.
HE SAYS, AND WE ARE QUOTING
HERE, "I MEAN, WHAT THE F."
IN OTHER WORDS, THESE GIRLS,
THEY ARE CRAZY, ALL OF THEM WANT
A PIECE OF CHRIS CUOMO.
MAYBE SOME OF THEM WANT TO GET
BENCH PRESS TO COME IF YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN?
THEY ARE MAKING UP THESE CRAZY
LIES, YOU KNOW, LIKE WOMEN DO,
HORMONES, PROBABLY.
MICHAEL COHEN IS NOT CONVINCED
BY THIS EXPLANATION.
EVEN MICHAEL COHEN TAKES WOMEN
MORE SERIOUSLY THAN THAT.
WELL, IT IS A PROBLEM, D7 BEGINS
TO SAY, BUT CHRIS CUOMO CUTS HIM
OFF.
WHEN YOU’RE TALKING TO CHRIS
CUOMO, YOU DON’T GET TO TALK
MUCH.
WE NEVER LEARN WHO ARE ALL OF
THESE WOMEN WHO CLAIM THEY HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY HARASSED BY CHRIS
CUOMO?
WHAT ARE THEIR NAMES?
HAD THEY RECEIVED FINANCIAL
SETTLEMENTS FROM CNN OR ABC?
WHEN WE ASKED THOSE QUESTIONS
YESTERDAY TO CNN, WE SENT THEM
THE TAPE YOU JUST HEARD, SOMEONE
AT THE P.I. P.R. DEPARTMENT, AND
WEIRD KID WHO HOSTS THE SHOW,
THEY DID NOT RESPOND.
WAS THEIR REACTION THE SAME AS
CHRIS CUOMO’S?
I MEAN, WHAT THE F?
WE CAN ONLY GUESS THEY THINK
WOMEN ARE CRAZY, CHRIS CUOMO
HASN’T CALLED US EITHER, YOU CAN
WE WORK IN THE MEDIA, AND IF
THERE IS ONE THING THAT CHRIS
CUOMO HATES, IT’S THE MEDIA.
OBVIOUSLY, HE DEFENDS THE MEDIA
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT ON HIS SHOW,
BUT HE DOESN’T MEAN IT, NOT AT
ALL, AS HE TOLD HIS OLD PAL,
MICHAEL COHEN, MORE THAN ONCE,